[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Welcome, everyone.
This is 14.13 Psychology
and Economics, also known
as Behavioral Economics.
My name is Frank Schilbach.
I'm a faculty member in
the Economics Department,
teaching and doing research
in Behavioral Economics
and Psychology and Economics
and Development Economics.
There's a syllabi over here
in case anybody needs one.
So let me sort of start
with introducing ourselves,
including myself.
As I said, I'm Frank Schilbach.
I'm an Economics PhD
from Harvard recently.
I'm from Germany in case--
as you may have noticed.
I do research at the
intersection of development
behavioral economics.
In particular, I'm
interested in integrating
psychological issues and
helping us understand
better the lives of the poor.
And so I study all sorts of
issues related to poverty,
how poverty itself
affects people's behavior,
and how conditions
of poverty, or things
that are associated with
poverty might feed back
into people's decision-making
and their productivity or labor
market behaviors.
And then perhaps, sort of lead
to the persistence of poverty
through those kinds of effects.
So I have some work on
financial constraints,
how financial constraints affect
people's behavior, in terms
of thinking about money itself.
I have some work on
sleep deprivation
among the urban poor.
I'm thinking about pain
and substance abuse
and how that might
affect people's choices.
Most recently, I'm
interested in things
related to mental health,
in particular, depression
and loneliness, how those might
affect people's well-being,
and then their behaviors.
I have office hours where you
can sign up on my websites.
Currently, they're on
Tuesday afternoons,
but if you cannot find
a time set work for you,
please email me and we'll
find some time that works out.
My assistant is
Krista Moody in case
you want to sort
of get a hold of me
and I'm not available
for some reason,
you can reach out to her.
So now, let me give you sort
of the overview of the class.
I'm going to start sort
of with four things.
One, first, I'm going
to sort of tell you
what is this class, what
is behavioral economics,
or what is psychology economics?
What do we mean by that?
Is it sort of just putting
two fields together,
or is this something
more specific,
which I'll argue it is.
I'm going to give
you some example then
about how you might use
behavioral economics,
and a specific example
and a policy that
might affect all of you.
And in fact, it will because
we have a specific laptop
policy in this class.
And I'll tell you a little
bit how to think about this.
There will also be a
problem set that'll
help you think about
this a bit more.
Then we talk about somewhat
boring, of course, logistics.
And at the end, we do a
questionnaire, a quiz,
for everybody, in
part, because we
want to know some
information for you.
In part, we want
to sort of learn
a little bit about some
decisions that you might make.
OK.
Great.
Sorry, this is--
OK.
So what is psychology economics?
So you may have heard of this.
The class used to be called
economics and psychology,
or behavioral economics.
For our purposes, that's
kind of like all the same.
Some economists sort of
argue that all economics
is about behavior.
So like behavioral economics is
sort of a bit of a weird word.
So that's why partially
I'm using sort of the word
psychology and economics.
In some sense, it's sort
of broader than that.
One definition is, "it's a
field of academic research
that studies the
joint influences
of psychological and economic
factors on behaviors."
You could be sort
of broader and say
we're trying to integrate
insights from not just
psychology, but also
anthropology, sociology,
medicine, psychiatry, et cetera,
and so on, into economics.
And trying with an attempt
to make economic models more
realistic, and therefore,
more predictive and help us
understand people's
behavior better.
And then help us make
better policies, perhaps,
in trying to influence
people's behavior.
Now, as I said, that's
medicine, sociology, et cetera.
Broadly, we're trying to use
insight from those fields
and try and understand
how we missed something
by making the fairly
stark assumptions
that economic
models usually make.
That leads me to what are then
the standard economics models?
In some sense, what we're going
to try and study to some degree
is deviations from
the classical,
or sort of the standard
economic model.
So then, of course, we
need to understand what
is the standard economic model?
To start with, which leads me
to impart some prerequisites
of the class, or you
should have taken
at least some economics or--
some economics to
start with because I'm
going to talk a lot about sort
of deviations from those models
and sort of--
if you haven't taken
any class before,
don't really know
that very well,
then understanding
the deviations
will be a little bit tricky.
So for those of you who
have taken economic classes,
what do you usually assume
about people's behavior?
What are some of the
assumptions that you
make about economic behavior?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Stable preferences.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Stable
preferences, yes.
So first, well-defined
preferences
in the sense of like people
know what their preferences are.
They can state them.
And then they're also
stable in the sense of when
I ask you today would you
rather have apples or bananas,
that will not change
unless there's
sort of new information or
your circumstances change.
Of course, if I ask you
tomorrow and you already
have a bunch of apples, and
then you'd say you want bananas,
that doesn't mean your
preferences of changed.
But if I ask you about tomorrow,
what would you like for lunch,
you tell me a choice, you want
apples rather than bananas.
And then tomorrow, you show up
and nothing else has changed
and you say, now,
I want bananas.
Well then, your
preferences are not stable.
That's one assumption, yes.
What else do you have?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: More broadly,
they're rational.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
And what does that mean?
AUDIENCE: They behaved
deterministically
to optimize some
utility function.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
So people essentially optimize
some utility function.
So we say here, people
have the utility function
and know what that is.
And you're sort of
saying they maximize it
to optimize in a certain way.
They don't make mistakes in
that maximization process.
So that's to say if you tell me
you like apples over bananas,
and then you choose bananas,
well then, something
is sort of going
wrong in some ways
that we haven't
fully understood.
It might be that you
sort of like just
making mistakes that could
be construed as irrational.
It's hard to rationalize
with a model.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Self-interest.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Self-interest, yes.
So like usually in a lot of
models all like this sort of--
the easiest model is a very
narrowly defined self-interest
is what people care
about themselves.
They care about
what they consume
and not about what
others consume,
or what others think of them.
So sort of narrowly
defined self-interest.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: People
have the self-control
to [? smooth their ?]
consumption over time.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
So essentially,
perfect self-control
usually is sort of one
version of putting that.
One version of putting that
is in some sense sort of going
back to what you saying
earlier is sort of
to say stable preferences.
If I'm telling you I'd
like to exercise tomorrow,
and that's my
preference, tomorrow I'm
not going to be like, oh, yeah,
actually, I changed my mind
and now I'm just watching
movies, or the like, right?
So that's the version of sort
of preferences being stable.
But the inherent
underlying issue there
is like self-control problems
in the sense of like,
if I like certain
things, or make
certain plans for the future,
I have the self-control
to follow through
on those plans.
That's usually an assumption.
And that then shows up as
preferences being stable.
What else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They prefer
consumption today
than consumption tomorrow.
[INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah.
So usually, there is
like a discount factor
in terms of how much you
like consumption today
versus consumption tomorrow.
That is usually in
any economic model.
Usually, we think of like the
discount factor being constant,
as like how you think
about today versus tomorrow
is the same as you think
about today versus in two
days from now, or like a year
from now and a year and a day
from now.
So usually, there's a constant
discount factor for the future.
Usually, we sort of
employ economic-- sorry--
constant discounting or
exponential discounting.
What else do we have?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Risk aversion.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Yes, risk aversion
in the sense of, I guess,
people are risk averse,
and people often sort of define
their preferences over outcome.
So they have a utility function
that we tend to concave,
and the utility
function is-- and we'll
get to this in a few lectures.
But the utility
function is concave
and it's defined over outcome
as opposed to over changes
of outcomes.
And that shows up usually
as sort of like essentially
like a strictly concave
utility function,
and that's risk aversion.
What about information, how do
people think about information?
How do they use information?
AUDIENCE: Bayesian.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Bayesian.
And what does that mean?
AUDIENCE: They update
[? their prior. ?]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So people essentially are
perfect information processors.
You can call them Bayesians.
But essentially, it's
sort of-- for those of you
know that-- it's sort of
did they use Bayes' rule,
essentially, which
is to say if you gave
a statistician a problem
how to update information,
people are able to do
that in their heads.
And that's a pretty
stark assumption.
But essentially, it's
like when you people have
certain information, standard
economics does not necessarily
assume that everybody has
full information in a sense
that everybody knows everything.
But if you give them
some information,
then they update their
beliefs accordingly, right?
So they-- essentially, they
optimally use new information
and then form their beliefs,
their posterior beliefs based
on having new information and
what they believe previously,
their priors.
There's another
assumption, usually,
and I sort of can
actually sort of
put these out for you, which
is, there's another assumption.
That is, people have no taste
for beliefs or information.
What do we mean by that?
We mean by that is,
essentially, people
use information only
to make decisions.
So if you tell me
something about
like what's going
to happen tomorrow,
or if you tell me something
about my health status,
or the like, I use that
to make better decisions.
So if you tell me I'm sick, I'm
going to use that information
to go to the doctor.
But people usually
don't assume that people
have certain beliefs
about whether they're
sick or healthy, or whether
they're smart or not,
or they are good looking or not.
Usually, the assumption
that beliefs are only
used-- information is only
used to make better decision.
Not that people get
utility from beliefs.
But instead, you
might say, well,
I'm really good
looking and smart,
and maybe smarter
than you actually are.
And the reason why
people might believe that
is because it makes them
feel good about themselves.
That's usually an assumption
that standard economic models
make.
I think we mentioned
almost everything.
We sort of said Bayesian
information processor--
essentially
processing information
optimally-- well-defined
and stable preferences,
maximize expected utility, which
is sort of like, in some sense,
rationality if you want, apply
exponential discount weighting
current and future well-being.
People are narrowly defined in
terms of their self-interest.
And people have preferences for
final outcomes, not changes.
So what you care about is
how the weather is today, not
kind of how the weather changed
between yesterday and today
or tomorrow.
And we'll talk
about all of these.
By the way, these are all
sort of some terms that
seem maybe unfamiliar to you.
We'll talk about all of
these kinds of assumptions
and perhaps how to deviate
from them specifically.
OK.
So now, that we have
those assumptions, now
what kinds of deviations when
you look into the world--
and sort of one
part how you think
about behavioral economics
is, in some sense,
think about the world,
and try to sort of observe
what's going on in the world.
And try to see which
assumptions might be
violated in an important way.
And try to sort of
improve our models.
So when you think
about the world
and look at these
assumptions, can you
come up with real world examples
that might sort of violate
these assumptions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The last
assumption that you
listed, the one of taste
and beliefs or information
is violated on a
constant basis, people
tend to believe what
they want to believe.
FRANK SCHILBACH: And do you
have an example, a specific?
AUDIENCE: This is very common
as it regards political matters.
I'm not going to name
a particular topic
because obvious reasons.
But people often choose to
discount information that
goes against their beliefs.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So one reason could be-- and
there's quite a bit of work
recently.
We'll talk a little bit about
in this class about sort
of how political
beliefs or other reasons
why people might be motivated
to believe certain things.
One clear example would be
climate change, not just
because of political reasons.
There's some
interesting work about,
when people live in
flood areas, for example,
what do they think
about climate change?
And you might sort of
say, well, if you really
live in an area that's
potentially affected by floods,
you might really want to
know about climate change
and know what's going on and
really try to inform yourself.
But what people tend to do is
sort of try to ignore the issue
and try to sort of be happy
as long as sort of nothing
happens.
Now, that's one example, yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Some purposes
might not be well-defined.
So say, I have a decision
on what I want to eat.
I want to eat steak
over chicken if I'm
presented with the opportunity.
But I prefer chicken over
pork, but I might else
prefer pork over steak.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
AUDIENCE: So it's not
always well-defined.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So one part that you're
telling is essentially--
so one part might be it might
not just be well-defined.
There's other issues,
like, for example,
that irrelevant other-- there's
an assumption economics.
Usually, as they say, if
you choose between A and B,
the availability of
C should not matter
for your choice between A and B.
But often, that's not the case.
So if I offer you
apples and bananas
and you also can
get cherries, now
suddenly your choice
between apples and bananas
might change even if you
can't get the cherries--
sorry, even if you don't
choose the cherries eventually.
Exactly.
There might be sort of
peoples' preferences
might not be well-defined.
They might also not be stable.
Any other example?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Also, for the
well-defined preferences,
we have information
processing constraints.
If I'm given a menu
of 100 choices,
it's going to be difficult
for me to know which one.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
So people have lots of
information around themselves.
And if you think about to
process that information,
if you go to a supermarket,
it's impossible to know
all the prices, all the goods,
and make all these choices.
So in some sense, there's
an abundance of information
everywhere.
And we have to sort of figure
out how to deal with that.
Any other example?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Some people who might
have preferences [INAUDIBLE]
equal an outcome
of getting $1,500
would be different
if you were initially
promised $1,000 versus
if you [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
So one part is to say
people have preferences
of a final outcome,
not changes, which
is to say you might feel about
the weather in certain ways,
you know, depending on how
the weather was yesterday.
Another version of that would
be you evaluate the outcomes
that you get based
on your expectations.
And sort of if you
thought, you know,
today is going to be really
nice or your day is going to be
really good, but then it
happened to be not as good
for whatever reason-- the
weather is bad or something bad
happen to you today--
the typical assumption
would be just say, well,
you should just evaluate
the final outcome.
It shouldn't matter what you
thought about previously what
might happen.
You're going to look at
what happens at the end.
And that's how you
evaluate your well-being.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You might need
a commitment device,
so that you--
you might avoid
buying potato chips
because you think
you'll eat them.
That didn't really make sense.
[INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So people might on purpose
restrict their choices
in certain ways, right?
And this is what
gets me eventually
to the laptop policy.
But people might
sort of essentially
know that in the future
they make certain choices.
For example, in the laptop
case, you might say,
I'm going to use
a laptop in class
with all the best intentions
to taking notes and paying
attention.
But you know, at
the end of the day,
you know, you're going to
watch the football review
from yesterday or whatever.
Other stuff comes up.
You're going to chat with your
friends and so on and so forth.
So now, in some sense, if
you're as sophisticated,
as in if you know what
you're going to do in case
you sort of make certain
choices, you might say,
I choose not to even allow
myself to use a laptop at all.
The reason being because I
know that essentially I'm going
to misbehave in the future.
And that's we'll
talk about this soon,
I think in lecture three or
four, which is essentially
people's demand for
commitment, as we
call it, which is to
say people have demand
for restricting their choice.
And in any neoclassical model,
this doesn't make any sense.
Because you're going to
choose optimally anyway.
And you're going to make
the best choice for yourself
in any case.
That's an assumption.
So why would you ever sort
of shut down certain choices?
Because, for example,
in an emergency,
or there might be
something really important
coming up in class
where you might
want to use your laptop
regardless of what's happening.
Why would you shut that down?
Exactly.
So demand for commitment
is another example.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: People are also not
anywhere near perfect Bayesian
information processors either.
Or as a general rule,
people are pretty
bad at updating their beliefs
based on new information.
And we frequently
traffic in 100% and 0%
certainties very often, which
far more often than what
you would expect from a
Bayesian information processor.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
AUDIENCE: Practically
not [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So one summary of
that is to say Bayes'
rule, a lot of this sort
of updating behavior,
is really hard.
It's actually tough to do.
And for those of you who do
statistics, math, et cetera,
you might be able to
do that very well.
But in a way you're
a very small share
of the population who
actually does that well.
But even among those,
there's a bunch of stuff
that's really hard to
compute in your head.
You might be able to write
it down and figure it out
eventually, but
usually the assumption
is that people just do all
of this stuff in their heads
and really complicated problems.
And that's sort of clearly not
the case in many situations.
And then, of course, that's
sort of one part of that sort
of among MIT students.
But then, you know,
there's other populations
that are less educated.
They might not even know
what Bayes' rule is.
They might be illiterate
and so on and so forth.
So the assumption of
people perfectly processing
information is even
perhaps more tenuous.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A lot of models
are usually hedonic,
but people usually
care about what
other people are doing as well.
So for example, I may not
be willing to take a class.
But if my friend takes a
class or gets into the class,
then my utility would go up.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So there's two parts to that.
This is essentially
the assumption
of narrowly defined
self-interest and people
caring only about themselves
or their own consumption.
So there's two parts of that.
One is you might care
about your friends.
You might give money
to your friends.
You might sort of help them out.
You might help
them with homework.
You might help them
in other situations.
You might send money to
charity and so on and so forth.
So this is kind of like you
care about other people.
And the well-being
of other people
is in your utility function
one way or the other.
The second part is
what you already
discussed as well, which is
kind of social influences,
call it, which is
essentially peer effects.
You care a lot about what
other people think about you.
You care a lot about
what other people do.
People get jealous.
People get angry.
People get envious.
And sort of their
behavior about what
they want at the end of the day
is very volatile and malleable,
essentially, based on
influences from others, right?
And that might sort of show
up in all sorts of ways,
including in terms
of peer effects.
People do all sorts of
things because other people
think that's cool.
But it's not necessarily
what's best for them
if they had to
choose on their own.
OK, great.
So let me stop here.
There's a lot of other examples
that we can come up with.
I have a few here.
So one is sort of
limited self-control.
That's one of my favorite
pictures about gym attendance
where you say, well,
they seem to be
people who have preferences
for going to the gym.
But then there's an
escalator, and people
not working out so much.
So in some sense, something
is perhaps amiss here.
When you look at sort of--
and this is one of my favorite
things to do is--
or not quite as-- it's a fun
thing to do, but maybe not one
of my favorite things.
When you sort of
Google terms, this
is calories or Weight
Watchers or the like,
where you say, well, what is
people's interest in googling
those kinds of terms over
the course of a year?
And as you can
imagine, what you see
are these spikes that are
essentially January 1st.
People start sort of
googling calories.
They start googling
Weight Watchers
and so on and so forth.
And now, of course, you can sort
think about some models that
sort of can rationalize this
in some sense in saying,
well, January is just a good
way to start a diet and so on.
But really the right thing
to do is sort of a people,
on January 1st, have all the
best of intentions to lose
weight, eat healthier, exercise
more, and so on and so forth.
And then the year
starts, the semester
happens and so on and so forth.
And the good intentions
sort of fade away,
which is essentially
limited self-control.
There's some interesting
things about demand
for information, especially
when it comes to health.
You know, every
time I ask this--
and I've taught this
class a few years so far.
Every time I ask this, I
sort of realize how old I am.
Who knows Dr. House?
Oh, not bad.
So can anybody explain to
me Thirteen and Dr. House
and what is sort of their deal?
And what does this have to do
with demand for information?
So who's Thirteen?
Or what is her health issues?
AUDIENCE: She's got a
genetic disease, I think.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes, she has--
AUDIENCE: She has, like--
I'm not--
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Huntington's, yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, Huntington's.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
AUDIENCE: He finds out later on.
So she has a disease, which is
called Huntington's disease,
which we'll also talk about more
in the class, which essentially
is a brain disease
where over time
your brain more or
less degenerates.
And it's a really bad
condition where at age 40, 50
that manifests.
And it's a very
serious condition.
It's a genetic
disease in the sense
of, if your parents
have that disease,
the chance of you
having it is way,
way higher than in the
general population.
There's a test for it,
but there's no cure.
So now, the dilemma
and the show then
comes where she essentially is
thinking about getting tested.
And Dr. House, who in
some ways very rational
and others not so
much, essentially
encourages her to get that test.
And any rational
model would say, well,
you should really get that.
Any sort of neoclassical
model would say,
you should get that test.
Why should you get the test?
Why is that helpful?
AUDIENCE: More information.
FRANK SCHILBACH: And what's
the information helpful for?
AUDIENCE: [? It ?]
[? would update ?] [? price ?]
[? of action. ?]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
You would say
information is good.
Why is information good?
Because there's lots
of important choices
that you might make that
depend on that information.
You might think about how
much money you want to save.
You think about your
choices about taking
a vacation, about career
choices, about partner choices,
about having children,
all sorts of issues
about health behaviors.
You might sort of take
better care of yourself.
There's all sorts of
really important decisions
that might hinge on the fact
your life will be dramatically
different whether you have
Huntington's disease or not.
Now, Thirteen does not want to--
I think she actually
does the test,
and then doesn't want to see
the result. And why is that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Even if you
have the condition,
there's no cure for the disease.
So it might help your quality
of life if you [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH:
So that's one view.
Just to view that, I think,
in some sense, as I said,
you could make other decisions,
like economic choices.
You could save more.
You could see the doctor more.
You could go more on
vacations or whatever,
do fun things in life.
But you could say, well, maybe
that's not that important.
But the neoclassical or the
classical economics model
would still argue that you
should get that information.
It wouldn't hurt you.
You wouldn't want to refuse it.
But why is she refusing it?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think
maybe she doesn't
want to live the
rest of her life
knowing she has the disease.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So she essentially derives
utility from information,
if you want, from her beliefs.
She likes to sort of pretend
to herself that she's healthy
or the chance of her being
healthy is very high.
Now, under some
assumptions, you might
want to not get tested and sort
of see the result of that test.
Because once you have the
test, if it's positive,
it's very hard to
pretend to yourself
that you're healthy
because there's
a hard test saying that.
Before the test, she
can still sort of think,
try to forget about it,
and try to sort of live
a happy life sort of
until the symptoms set in.
But that's a clearer violation
of the classical model
of the assumptions that
I was showing you above.
The next part is
default effects.
So what I'm showing over
here is the fraction
of organ donors by country
and type of default.
There's two types of defaults,
often, for organ donations.
This is from a few years ago,
but I think, overall, things
have not changed that much.
There's opt-in versus opt-out.
So in the countries on
the left, essentially
you have an opt-in policy.
In a sense, if you
don't do anything,
you're not an organ donor.
So you have to actively
say in some form
or some form of declaration that
you want to be an organ donor.
On the right, there's
opt-out policies,
which means essentially,
if you don't do anything,
you'll be automatically
registered or viewed
as an organ donor.
You can opt out, but
only if you do so,
you'll actually be opted out.
Otherwise, if there's
an accident or the like,
you'll be viewed
as an organ donor.
Now, what's weird
about this graph?
Or why is this sort of
potentially a violation
of the neoclassical or the
typical economics assumptions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Because assuming
that the people have
the same preference of whether
they want to opt-in or opt-out,
then there should be the
same proportion across.
But the difference is
that the effort required
to make that change or
the lack of indifference
causes there to be the
imbalance between the opt-out
and the opt-in.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
So some people in--
I don't want to get in
trouble, but some people
would argue Germany and Austria
is actually not that different.
So I'm German.
So some Austrians
might disagree.
But you would say, you know,
overall, Germans and Austrians
are not that different overall.
And you think, you know, their
preferences in particular,
they might be different.
But their preferences
for organ donations
are probably pretty similar
across those two countries,
which is a reasonable
assumption.
Second, lots of
people care a lot
about what happens to them
after they die, right?
So they, for whatever
reasons, religious or other,
they might actually
care a lot about,
at the end of the day,
what happens to their body
and so on.
And that's obviously
their choice to make.
Now, if you assume
those two things,
then it's very hard to
reconcile this picture.
Because, essentially,
the opt-in and opt-out
is a very small change to make.
It's very simple and easy to do.
You just have to
fill out some form.
Maybe it takes you
an hour, maybe two.
You have to maybe go to
some office or the like.
But if you really care,
you could easily do it.
Yet you see huge
differences in outcome
based on this very simple
small change, which
is very hard to model or
write down a model that sort
of rationalizes this behavior.
So somehow the default, sort of
the way in which the decision
is presented, seems to really
affect people's behavior
in a fundamental way.
OK, next one is GlowCaps.
This is help for people to take
their medication, in particular
for the elderly,
which essentially
is a reminder for people.
You can sort of program this
in certain ways, like every day
or every few hours, GlowCaps.
So it's either sort
of making sounds
or such blinking and
the like and gets
you to take your medication.
And it's a very sort of
simple proof of concept
that reminders are important
and can save people's lives.
And people have done
studies on that and so on.
But essentially, it's a
very simple proof of concept
that memory is limited, right?
If your memory was perfect, if
you could remember everything,
if you were a perfect
information processor,
you would not forget
about your medication,
especially if it's
important, especially
if it's medication that
potentially saves your life.
Yet we see that people's
medication usage is strongly
affected by sort of types
of policies or products
that can help people remember.
So that's essentially a
rejection of perfect memory.
Next one is charity.
So if you think about
people in all sorts of ways
seem to care about others in
the sense of just giving money,
here's one charity that's
called GiveDirectly, which
is a very nice charity in
a sense that what it does,
essentially, is a very simple
way of helping the poor by just
directly transferring
money to poor countries.
So on the right, you
see an actual recipient
from GiveDirectly.
That person has a phone.
They're sort of a mobile
phone based transfers
where, essentially,
you can send money
to people with mobile phones.
So if you decided now to
give $100 to that person--
it could be that person
or a similar person--
95 of those or 90 of those
dollars would then, in fact,
arrive at the cell
phone of that person.
Now, why are people doing this?
Presumably, because
they care about others
one way or the other.
It could be either that,
in some sense, that's
part of the utility function.
Just donating money to
others makes you happier.
And that's essentially a way in
which you improve your being.
You just have others well-being
in your utility function.
Or it could be things like
what we said previously.
It could you sort of think
it's appropriate thing to do.
Maybe other people do.
It's an important thing to do.
Maybe you can tell
your friends about it
and so on and so forth.
But one way or the other,
people give lots of money
to charity, which in some sense
says, one way or the other,
you must care about
others overall.
So others are in your
utility function.
So now, attention, if you
have seen this before,
don't tell your
friends about it.
Here's a simple attention
test that I want you to do.
What's interesting about
this is, in some ways,
you might have seen this before.
Some of you may have
seen the gorilla before.
Who didn't see the gorilla?
That's OK.
I didn't see it either.
But some people
have seen it before.
There's a bunch of
experiments that people
have done that essentially show
that, often, a large fraction
of people don't
see this gorilla.
And there's various
ways in which people
do other types of experiments.
There's types of experiments
where essentially people,
they go to some bank teller.
The bank teller says, I'm going
to go away and then comes back.
And then there's a different
person who comes back,
and people don't notice.
There's various
versions of that.
And so what's interesting
about this in some sense is--
so A, it proves, in some ways,
that attention is limited.
You just focus your attention
on some things and not others.
And you might miss
important things.
Now, that's OK in some ways.
There's sort of a version
of that that says, well,
it might be sort of
rational inattention.
In some sense, you focus on
the important things in life.
And you might miss some
things, and that's OK.
In some sense, I asked you,
or the video asked you,
to count the number of passes.
So in some sense, the
gorilla is irrelevant.
And that's true in this case.
But in many other cases,
people might sort of not
rationally pay attention.
They might sort of miss
some really important things
in their lives in
part because they're
distracted, in part
because they don't want
to pay attention and so on.
And some strand of
behavioral economics
which we'll talk
about is sort of when
people do not pay
attention and then make
mistakes because of that.
OK.
So I could go on and on with
lots of different examples.
But the bottom line here is that
most researchers in psychology
economics believe that the
classical model of behavior,
sort of the homo economicus,
is too extreme in various ways.
That person is too selfish,
too rational, and too willful.
And in some ways, we want
to kind of understand
how relaxing some
of these assumptions
might make economic
models more realistic.
Now, in some sense, no
economist would, in fact,
argue that the assumptions
of the standard models
are exactly correct.
The questions are, are
these deviations important?
Do they actually
matter for something
important in explaining
people's behavior?
And which of those assumptions
or deviations actually matter?
And that's kind of the
name of the game here.
In fact, when you talk
to cognitive scientist,
psychologist, et cetera,
they will tell you the world
is full of cognitive biases.
And you might not be
able to read this.
And that's kind of the point.
There's so many different
things in which we are biased.
In some sense, every
choice that we make
or any things that
we do, there's
lots of biases that interfere
with people's choices.
And almost any choice
you can think of
or any behavior they
can think about,
there will be psychology
or other experiments
showing that people do
not behave perfectly.
Now, the key question then
is, which of those assumptions
are important?
And which of those violations of
assumptions should we focus on?
And for that, I want to
step back a little bit
and say, OK, what
is actually a model?
What are economic
models trying to do?
And so what is a model?
A model is a simplified
representation of the world.
And we know, in some sense, that
the assumptions of the models
are not true.
They're sort of supposed to be
approximately true and exactly
false.
So when you think about
used models of the Earth,
in some sense, they're
flat, spherical, ellipsoid,
and so on and so forth, models.
Now, good models do not
account for bumps and grooves
and so on.
A perfect replica of the Earth
is not a useful model to use.
You kind of want to
simplify and capture
the essence of what's important.
So now, then what's
a good model?
Well, a good model-- and you can
read a bit about this in Gabaix
and Laibson's paper.
A good model is
supposed to be simple.
It's supposed to be easy
to work with and tractable.
So in some sense, you
have only a few variables,
a few things that matter.
It's conceptually
insightful in the sense
that it focuses on
important things.
It tells you about
behavior that we really
care about and important ideas.
It's generalizable in a
sense that, ideally, we
are trying to look for some
behaviors that are generally
in some sense.
So if I can just explain you
one simple choice in one domain
and write a model about
it, but that model
doesn't apply for
anything else, that's
not a good model to work with.
The model is supposed to
be falsifiable in a sense
that we can actually test them.
And that's kind of what we do
in experimental and behavioral
economics.
We try to test people's
theories and then empirical work
and then sort of falsify or
reject models that are wrong
and sort of accept
or do not reject
models we think are better.
There's supposed to be empirical
consistency in a sense of,
if I explain one
behavior, I should also
explain this over time
or in different domains.
And we should be able
to make good predictions
for people's behavior.
Now, are the assumptions
of the standard models
true for most people?
The answer is no.
But the key insight here, the
key properties of good models,
is simplicity.
So in some sense, assuming
perfect rationality,
selfishness and willpower
is actually a simple thing
to do in some sense.
The reason why economists
have made those assumptions
to start with is not
necessarily because they thought
people are perfectly
rational or that there
are not these psychological
issues going on.
The reason is
actually simplicity.
It's an easy thing to do.
You model how you think
people should behave
and how they behave perfectly.
And making some of these
models sort of richer
in their psychology is
actually complicated
and makes the models more
complex and harder to analyze.
So that is just to say,
well, then the question is,
can we find some
assumptions of economics?
Can we make them more
realistic in a tractable way?
In a sense, can
we find key things
that we change that keep
the models tractable
while then also explaining
important things better
than we can before?
So it's not about
just taking all sorts
of psychological issues
that might be going on
and say, well, economic
assumptions are wrong
or models of economics are wrong
or the assumptions of those
are wrong.
We know that these
assumptions are wrong.
The question is, can we make
somewhat simple assumptions
or improvements of
those assumptions
based on insights
from psychology
and other fields that help
us improve those models
and then make better
predictions and all
of that in a tractable way?
So now, this is
very important here.
A good behavior economist or
a good student in this class
is also a good economist.
Behavioral economics
is not sort of trying
to replace standard economics.
So I don't want you
to go to my colleagues
and say, you know, 1401, 1402,
and so on, this is all garbage.
Frank is telling you we
do things differently.
In fact, you very much need
to know those kinds of things
from standard
economics to understand
what the assumptions are and how
to best to deviate from that.
And so such then, key principles
of mainstream economics
continue to apply.
Decision makers are still
highly sophisticated.
Markets and incentives matter.
They, in fact, play a key
role in shaping behavior.
And markets allocate resources
well most of the time.
The question is, can we sort of
focus on important deviations
and try to fix those?
And then, again, sort of
methodological principles
still apply.
Use observational
experimental data.
Mathematical models are
good and so on and so forth.
And ideally, models
would sort of
finesse the special
case of perfect
rationality or perfectly sort
of standard economic models.
And they try to build
in some parameters that
deviate from that
and try to understand
can we make better predictions.
And then so, often,
prices are actually
the most important
aspects of choice.
Here's one experiment
by Ito et al.
that try to essentially sort
of change people's energy usage
and so on.
And they have two treatments.
One is called moral
suasion, which
essentially is telling people--
sort of appealing to
their morals in some ways.
And the other one is essentially
just financial incentive,
straight up changing the
price of people's choices.
And what you see in this
experiment essentially
is there's, in red,
you have the impact.
These are all treatment effects
over time comparing a treatment
group and a control group.
And you see, in red,
the treatment effects
of the incentives.
And you see these are relatively
large and persist over time.
And you see the treatment
effects of the moral suasion
treatment, which happens to be
reasonably large to start with,
but essentially just goes away.
What did we learn from that?
We've learned from
that prices matter.
And maybe in this
case, moral suasion
is just not that important.
And that's perfectly fine.
We're trying to identify
situations or cases
where some of the underlying
psychological issues
are important.
And we've learned from an
experiment that, in some cases,
it doesn't apply.
Well, so be it.
Then we should
focus on other cases
where the psychological
issues are more important.
OK.
So then what's sort of our
broad approach to each topic?
We're trying to sort of start
with an intuitive, empirical,
and experimental
examples how people
behave in some situations.
We try to think about
their motivations,
try to see about how they
make choices and behaviors
and how they behave
in certain situations.
And then we're going to
try and sort of model this
in a more precise way
and try to consider
how the modeling of
that perhaps deviates
from the neoclassical or the
classical model of economics.
Some other times,
you also just start
from the classical
model of economics,
look at the predictions, and
say, well, can we reject that?
Or do we make
certain predictions
that are just not true?
And then say, can
we sort of improve
those types of assumptions?
And then, overall, we're
trying to think about then
how these hypotheses
or deviations might
be able to explain how
people behave in markets
and what choices they
make and how, perhaps, we
can think about policies that
might affect the people's
well-being, their welfare,
or any other consequences.
Any questions so far?
OK.
So now, I want to give you one
very simple, in some sense,
stylized example which sort of
demonstrates a little bit what
sort of the neoclassical
economic standard
economic assumptions are
and how sort of enriching
a model with psychological
considerations
might be more powerful.
So when you think
about laptops in class,
what are sort of standard
economic considerations?
Should you allow laptops?
Should there be
laptops in class?
Is that a good thing
or a bad thing?
Or what do you think about that?
And now, I'm asking for
standard, non-psychological
issues, just saying, if you
went to a classical economist
and say, should we
allow laptops in class,
what would be
considerations for that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Externalities--
if you're distracting
people who are around you?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
So you could call that
psychological or not.
But essentially, it could
distract people essentially.
And externalities tend
to be sort of, very
much in classical economics--
essentially, if you smoke,
it affects others.
Similarly, if you had a
laptop, it might affect others.
It's a little bit
sort of in the middle
between psychological and
economic considerations.
Because in some sense,
if somebody next to you
would use a laptop, then
I would just say, well,
why don't you just
focus on class anyway?
You should be able
to just ignore that.
But setting that aside
that exactly externalities
are surely one
considerations that we have.
What's the pro-side?
Or why would we allow laptops?
What's good about
laptops in class?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It could just be
efficient for taking notes.
Some people might
need to use them.
Some people may are
dyslexic, stuff like that.
So it's just good.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
It's a useful technology
to take notes.
And you might just
be better at that
or might be more comfortable.
It's easier for you to do.
Maybe it also saves
some paper or whatever.
What else are laptops good for?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: More choice
is just always better.
So if each person
has their laptop,
they can choose what's better
for them to pay attention--
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes, exactly.
If you are so inclined
and want to watch football
from yesterday, the replay
and so on, if you prefer that
and that's good
for you, you know,
who should be
stopping you, right?
And so in some sense, laptops
are useful for note taking.
They're also useful for
non-class activities.
And as you say,
each student should
be able to choose for
themselves what's good.
And that may involve
paying attention or not.
Now, what are sort of some
psychological considerations?
We had one of them,
which essentially
distracting others, which
essentially is the externality.
What else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Temptation and not
valuing your future learning?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
You might sort of
have all the best
intentions of taking notes,
what I said previously.
But then, you know,
it gets a little dull
and boring at minute 40.
And you might sort of be
inclined to sort think
about other stuff
and sort of start
surfing an internet or the like
or start chatting or whatever.
That's sort of essentially
limited self-control one
way or the other.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I think even if you don't
fall into the temptation,
you kind of have to spend
energy resisting the temptation
and that might kind
of distract you.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So there's some
cognitive resources
potentially from that.
That's a very nice observation.
Exactly.
That also might be true.
There's another
part to that, which
is people tend to overestimate
how much they can multitask.
And there's a large
number of experiments
that say, well, I'm
actually paying attention.
I'm just sort of reading
some other stuff.
I'm chatting with my friend.
And people actually think they
pay attention, and they learn.
Trust me, they do not.
So essentially, there's a large,
large literature on people
thinking that they can multitask
when, in fact, they cannot.
And this is a very
human thing to do.
You might think you can study
for an exam by watching TV.
Chances are you're not
studying very well.
So that's essentially some
form of overconfidence.
Right.
And then there's
another part, which
is a sort of somewhat different
psychological consideration,
which is people tend to not
like hard paternalism, as in,
if you sort of--
we talk about this at the very
end when we talk about policy.
People don't like
certain hard rules
about you're allowed
to do this, or you
don't allow to do x or y.
You have to come to
class or whatever.
People tend to not like that.
That's more another
sort of consideration
if you think about what
is the right policy to do.
Now, what policy
solutions could we do?
What laptop policies
have you seen?
Or how do you think about them?
Maybe somebody else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I haven't seen it,
but let the people with laptops
sit in the back.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
You could do that.
Yeah.
And sort of that's kind of
minimizing the externality
potentially.
It's not really helping with
self-control, I guess, right?
Because particularly,
if you sit in the back,
nobody sees what you're doing.
And you might be so inclined
to do all sorts of things.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I've had professors
say a hard no on laptops,
but if you have
special needs or if you
think you're a
special case, you can
tell the professor [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So that's sort of
like hard paternalism
with some exceptions
potentially.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I've seen
only devices that
are flat on the table
allowed for [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: For
note-taking, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I've seen
TAs sitting in the back
and keeping track of
class participation.
So if they see you doing
something not academic,
they could technically
ding you for it.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah.
That's what they're for.
No.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: I've seen
classes where you're just
allowed to use your
laptop because, I guess,
you're an adult. And you're
responsible for letting
you learn.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
That's sort of
laissez-faire and saying
you know what's best for you.
In some sense,
since this is sort
of a psychology and
behavioral class,
I tend to disagree with
some of those assumptions.
But, yes, exactly.
That's laissez-faire.
Any other thoughts?
OK.
So then here they are.
So there's laissez-faire.
There's educational intervention
which essentially is providing
people information
about laptops or what
laptops do for learning.
There's some experiments
I'll show you in a second.
Educational interventions
tend to actually
not work particularly well.
So essentially, just
giving people information
tends to not change
behavior often
in the way we'd like to do that.
You could tax laptop use.
You say, it's
costly to, but that
would be the typical sort
of public economic sort
of solution.
I think I'm not allowed to
take money from you guys.
So I might not do that.
You could ban laptops.
That was a previous suggestion
to say except for students
with medical need.
You could make a non-laptop
section the default
and let students opt out or
opt in depending on that.
It's essentially saying,
the default choice
is one, essentially no laptops.
But you can opt into
that by emailing to a TA
and then use it in
a certain section.
We'll talk about, in the
problem set, a little bit why
that might be a good idea.
You could also set up an active
choice between the laptop
and the no laptop sections.
So here's the educational
interventions.
The evidence-- and there's
very clear evidence
from various settings that
shows that laptops in class
are not good for
learning on average.
There's a very nice article by
Susan Dynarski in The New York
Times.
We'll put this online as
well that you could read.
But essentially,
one of these studies
is a randomized
controlled trial that,
actually, an MIT grad student,
a former MIT grad student had
done, in an intro econ class.
This is Carter et al.
And essentially
what they find is
that allowing computers in
class reduced test scores
by 0.18 standard deviations.
That's quite a large number.
That's essentially saying they
did randomize across classes,
like at the classroom level,
whether they allowed laptops
in class or not.
Interestingly, they
found negative effects
both of unconstrained laptops,
like on any laptop use,
but also the flat
tablet solution.
So even the flat tablet
solution was worse
than sort of the note-taking
with pen and paper.
You know, and there's
a bunch of evidence
that sort of shows that.
So in this class,
what we're going
to have a sort of a version
of an opt-in policy, which is
there's going to be a
laptop section starting
next class, which is going
to be in the front on one
side of the class.
The reason being we're trying to
sort of minimize externalities.
It's in the front,
not in the back.
The reason being that, if
you're in the very back,
then there's no supervision.
I'll, I guess, ask some TAs
to sit sort of in the back.
If there's too much other
activities going on,
maybe there won't be a
laptop section anymore.
Anyway, there will be
sort of considerations
about that in the problem set.
But the point of all
of that is to say,
if you just had the standard
economic considerations,
you would make certain
policies on very sort
of simple considerations
by missing important facts.
And that might be sort of the
psychological externality.
It might be the self-control
problems, the overestimation
of people's ability to multitask
and so on and so forth.
And all of those
things might sort of
interfere with people's
optimal choices.
And that makes certain
more paternalistic policies
potentially more promising.
But again, in the problem
set, you'll think about some
of these solutions.
Any questions on the laptops?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I might be thinking
of a different study,
but if this is the
same one, I got
that, in their other classes,
they previously were not
allowed to use laptops.
So it might be that they
had not optimized themselves
for laptop usage during class.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
That's interesting.
So I think there are several
studies that show that.
I don't know the
details on that.
But if you can send that to
me, I'm happy to look at that
and reconsider.
I think my view overall is that
sort of the existing evidence
essentially shows
laptops are bad.
Since I'm interested
in your learning,
that's what I go with.
But I'm happy to be educated.
I'll try and put the slides
online always the night
before in case you want to
print them out or look at them
or whatever during class.
You're welcome to do that.
OK.
So then let me tell
you very briefly
about different
topics of the class
and what we're going to cover.
So first, we're going
to have an introduction
and overview of today's
introduction lecture.
The overview will
be on Wednesday,
which will providing
you an overview of what
the different topics are
and how to think about them
and what evidence
do we actually have.
So I was kind of a
little bit handwavy
in a sense of showing you lots
of flashy pictures of people
misbehaving.
But in fact, I'm going
to show you some more
sort of rigorous evidence
that we have that, in fact,
some of the assumptions
of the classical model
are violated and sort of
how we think about them
and how we might
sort incorporate them
into economics.
So that's going to be an
overview on Wednesday.
Then we're going to talk
a lot about preferences.
You can think about essentially,
when people make choices,
there's a utility function.
And sort of one set of
behavioral economics issues
are changes to the
utility function.
This might be time preferences
and people's self-control,
which we already discussed.
It might be risk preferences,
how people think about risk,
how they think about
gains and losses
and how their preferences
are reference-dependent.
This is what a student was
saying earlier about how
you evaluate
something might depend
a lot on your expectation
of that outcome as opposed
to just the outcome itself.
Then we're going to talk quite
a bit about social preferences.
This is sort of like
how much we weigh
others' utility and
our utility function
or their consumption and
our utility function.
We'll do some
experiments in class
on that, which should
be a lot of fun,
and then discuss
various issues about,
A, how much people
care about others
and how they're
affected by others'
behavior and social influences.
So that's kind of the first
half of the class broadly
about changes in
people's preferences.
Then we're going to talk
more about beliefs broadly
speaking and sort of how people
view information in the world.
We talk a little
about emotions, what's
called projection
and attribution bias.
These are issues
about, for example,
when people are
hungry or tired, they
might make quite
different choices.
And so that might affect
their preferences.
But it might also affect
their beliefs in some sense.
If you think about how
you're going to behave,
if you're hungry right
now, it's very hard for you
to believe or think
about that you might not
be hungry in the future.
This is sort of the
classical example is
shopping on an empty stomach.
There's lots of different
applications of that.
There's people buy
convertibles when it's sunny
and then return
them when it rains.
But there's also much
more serious issues,
in particular things
like depression.
For example, when
people are depressed,
it's very hard for
them to think about how
it might feel when they're
not depressed anymore
in the future.
So we'll talk about sort of
projection and attribution
bias, which is kind
of these biases
and how to think about
people states of the world.
How about limited
attention, that people
sort of don't pay
attention to certain things
in the world and sort of how
that might affect people's
behavior, how we might sort
of exploit that potentially
if we're taxing them or
how we might sort of direct
their attention
to certain things
and might improve
their behavior?
Similarly, then we talk
about beliefs and learning.
This is kind of like
what information
do they have available--
A, how they update their beliefs
when they get information.
And are they able to
process information well?
B, is there demand
for information?
Do people get
utility from beliefs?
This is what I was
talking about like health
behaviors or the health
information where people might
have motivated
beliefs in the sense
that they like to believe
certain things when,
in fact, they're
not true in part
because it makes them happy
or in part because they
want to be right about something
or their party or whatever.
We'll talk a little about
augmental accounting,
which is people tend to sort of
narrowly bracket their choices.
They might sort of have certain
accounts in their behavior
and decide sort of separately
as opposed to aggregating
their behavior as a whole.
And that's sort
of an issue that's
less researched, but
quite interesting overall.
Then we're going to
move towards sort
of more radical
deviations, if you want,
from the standard model,
which is things malleability
and accessibility
of preferences,
which is to say people might not
actually know what they want.
They might not even understand
what their preferences are
or their preferences
are easily manipulable.
I can sort make you choose A or
B or A versus B or B versus A,
depending on what kind of
situation I put you in.
And you might not even
notice that I'm doing that.
And that makes things
a lot trickier.
Because then, in
some sense, it's
much harder to
sort of say should
the government or any
sort of other policy maker
choose A or B if
we don't even know
what people's preferences are,
when people don't even know
what their own preferences are?
We're going to talk about
happiness and mental health.
Just kind of broadly speaking,
what makes people happy?
And can we think about
that, in particular, sort
of financial choices and others?
I'll tell you a
little bit about some
of the work on
mental health that I
have been doing, thinking about
kind of how mental health might
affect economic
behaviors and choices
and, in part, how people's
demand for mental health
interventions might be shaped
by influences of others.
We're going to talk about gender
and racial discrimination,
which sometimes there's sort
of classical and neoclassical
models of discrimination.
But we, in particular,
think about sort
of issues of discrimination
that are sort of not
rational in the sense of think
about unfair, in some sense,
discrimination.
Finally, we're going
to talk about sort
of policy and paternalism.
One broad issue is
about-- and this goes back
to malleability and
inaccessibility of preferences,
which is essentially
ways in which choices
can be affected through
frames, defaults, and nudges.
And sometimes I say, I
can manipulate your choice
architecture in
certain ways that
make you choose certain things.
You know, I might sort of send
you letters to do your taxes.
I can sort of frame or
set certain defaults
for organ donations or for
savings choices and the like.
And that might have profound
effects on people's behavior.
Once we go through that
in a sense of showing
you some evidence that it's
possible to do that, we're
going to talk a little bit
about policy and paternalism
in a sense of say, OK,
now, if I know I can change
your behavior in certain
ways, what kinds of policies
should we do?
And should we, in fact, do that?
Or should we tax people?
Should we set certain
frames and defaults?
And you know, are we
potentially making
some people worse off while
making some people better
off by doing these
kinds of policies?
There's often also some ethical
issues associated with that.
And then, finally, I'm
going to talk about poverty.
This is sort of mostly
the research that I do
and thinking about
poverty issues
through the lens of psychology.
Again, I'll tell you a little
bit about the work I do myself.
Partially, we get
to talk a little bit
about so how financial
constraints or just thinking
about money affects people's
behavior and then, second, how
others' issues
related to poverty
might shape people's
choices, decision making,
and their labor market
outcomes, earnings, and so on
and where there's
potentially something
that you might want to call
a psychological or behavioral
poverty trap.
Any questions on these topics?
OK.
So then readings for next
time, this is Wednesday.
Please read-- there's a paper
on the course website by Matthew
Rabin, who is one of
sort of the all-stars
in behavioral economics.
20 years ago, he wrote a
very useful perspective
on psychology and economics
that sort of discusses
a lot of the issues of
behavioral economics,
how to think about that.
Again, read sections
one and two.
We're not going to
test you specifically
on very specific things,
but you should sort of
be able to sort of remember,
at least roughly, what's
in that paper.